you want to talk about real high prices
this is something you're certainly not
going to hear in cnn or msnbc or any of
the liberal media
gas prices have just hit record highs
16 days in a row
in a row so it's not just wow gosh we've
hit the record high it's wow we've hit
the the highest gas prices since
yesterday
yes the highest gas prices since
the day before that
yes then you go back 16 days and then
you say we've hit the highest gas prices
since ever
this according to
aaa
on monday you had the record high for
the 16th consecutive day according to
triple a gas prices have risen about 15
cents since last week they've risen more
than 55 cents in one month and on monday
the average in the country was five
dollars
and one cent and in certain places it's
six dollars
it's seven
dollars who could have predicted this
all of the genius experts
all of the the responsible adults who
wear the ties on tv they told us this
isn't that's not going to happen
that's not going to happen you're not
going to have high gas prices you're not
going to have a concerted effort to
trans the kids in schools you're not
going to have crime in the streets
you're not going to you're not going to
have the things that we were we're
seeing around us
but i seem to recall at least one person
predicting all of these things and the
person who accurately predicted all of
these things
is the person who has been most smeared
by the experts and the geniuses as the
national buffoon
before i took office there was a lot of
folks out there a lot of folks out there
making some pretty bold predictions
about how things would turn out
you might remember some of the
predictions they're coming for your guns
they're coming for your jobs
and they're coming for your freedom they
hate american energy and joe biden will
shut it all down he's going to biden's
elected he will wipe out your energy
industry gas prices going five six seven
dollars for a gallon flood your
communities with criminal aliens drugs
and crime while they live behind
beautiful gated compounds spent
trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders do you want to use the
word recession or depression
it goes on that was a great video made
by maze a video producer i i caught it
on twitter it goes on and on and on
trump was right about pretty much
everything all of those predictions and
at the time what was the reaction the
reaction wasn't just an angry denial
from the libs the reaction was mockery
scorn derision
mr president okay come on can you
believe this guy can you oh my only a
dumb stupid idiot would ever believe
this guy you should believe me
i'm a guy who's wearing a tie on
television and i'm a very serious person
and i'm here to tell you there will not
be a war in ukraine and there won't be
high gas prices and there won't be
inflation or treasury secretary so
you're not going to get crazy inflation
don't that's a crazy no come on so all
the serious people the really super
duper serious people who tell you if you
get the shot you won't catch covid you
won't transmit covid oh no we're the
super serious people just mutilate your
kids bodies and that'll make them really
happy someday trust us
don't trust that idiot buffoon donald
trump
and who was right trump was right about
everything
the right wingers have been right
about
everything
even even the eccentric ones even the
really kind of crazy kooky wild puts on
a big show people you think about alex
jones right alex jones probably
one of if not the most eccentric figures
on the right and he said lots of things
that are all kind of wild and everything
but just compare for a second i'm not
saying everything alex jones has ever
said is right it's not
compare
the record of an alex jones to the
record of
brian stelter
or
chris wallace
or
chuck todd
or joe biden or dr fauci or any of the
super serious people in the liberal
establishment compare them to the most
cartoonishly outrageous eccentric person
on the right alex jones
it's not even close
jones has a way better record than any
of those people do
and then you want to move a little less
eccentric
someone like a donald trump
it's not it's not even close
who's the real adult in the room here
who's got the real grasp on the science
who's got the real grasp on common sense
who's got the real grasp on politics and
philosophy and theology and all the rest
of it
i'm not saying any of these people are
perfect or even close to it but the
right just
it's it's not even
comparable
it's not even
close
meanwhile our
wonderful adult in the room returned to
normalcy president who got the most
votes of anyone ever in the whole
history of democracy joe biden doesn't
even remember
where he's going
have you decided whether to go to saudi
arabia
no not yet what would be the of holding
up the decision at this point are there
commitments you're waiting for from the
saudis or on the negotiations over
people
the
commitments from the saudis
don't relate to anything having to do
with energy
it happens to be a larger meeting taking
place in saudi arabia that's the reason
i'm going and it has to do with national
security for them for israelis i have a
program anyway it has to do with much
larger issues than having to do with the
energy
did you catch that contradiction there
he said first question mr president are
you going to saudi arabia i don't know
mr president yeah so that's why i'm
going to saudi arabia he changed his
mind in the same answer
did you notice also how offensive his
answer was i said are you going to talk
about energy he said i'm not talking
about energy i'm talking about way more
important stuff
like israel and our relations in the
middle east and bigger problems in the
region and in arabia and much bigger
issues much more important issues than
american citizens paying seven dollars a
gallon in some places for gas i don't
think those are bigger issues
i think they're big issues i think it's
important to figure out
middle eastern peace and our relations
with certain gulf states and our
relations with israel and how that
reacts relates to our relations with
iran yeah sure that's all very important
i am more concerned
with american energy costs
i am more concerned with american
industry i'm more concerned with america
and the american citizens
he mocks it he laughs it off he doesn't
even know where he's going i'm glad you
like that clip now
you got a ring
bing bam wada wada ding dong ring that
bell and subscribe get the notifications
to the michael knowles show head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play myspace xanga aol instant messenger
the fax machine wherever you get your
audio podcasts subscribe to the michael
knoll show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]